oh oh oh
[Musique]
vous êtes prêt sort
dans votre canapé sans jamais nous
happer depuis le début vous m'avez
soutenu
personne ne pense
djazia m voilà lots papilles mais qui
passe à chantonnay mayapo choix
d'acheter par est quoi mais ça va pas
mal non la piste est selon moi c'est là
où vous quittez depuis l'auto dérision
[Musique]
le lac est situé ce commandant
j'aime mes frais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est
bombay
saleh
deux de ces données
what what i télé
[Applaudissements]
le cas
juste avant
[Musique]
tenez
supra
que dans ce monde étrange où j'irai
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le garde en vue
ah mais non j'ai donc
mais non non non pas du tout l'été mais
non
j'espérais tout l'hiver pédant mais
comme dit le proverbe
bonne nouvelle car il
[Applaudissements]
à
elle est
y a plein de choses à fond alors on
remarque l'éclectisme
il ya quand même des domaines mots quand
il se serait dit mercury bosser les
sardines c'est plus son truc
vocalement mon appartement qui ne sont
pas très bien rigole quand même il ya eu
la période kenji chirac il y avait
michael ossi oui patrick sébastien
évidemment beaucoup leurs api les
étrangers où il faisait du franglais un
peu parce que chante en anglais c'est ça
ou alors ça tout à l'heure on aura un
petit magnéto parce que cyril et la
langue anglaise
ça fait pas d'eux ça fait 4 1